ce qu'il n'avait pas suivi les épisodes
précédents une première mise en bouche
sorti la plage réussi premier virement
de bord réussi deuxième bord de près
deuxième virement de bord couler bien
c'est à dire qu'en vingt minutes tu as
appris le monde de la yole pour les nuls
et hier après-midi par contre j'étais à
sainte anne avec les les killers quoi
les bras ils m'ont appris à faire de la
yole sur de la mer plus plate déjà et là
je me suis régalé en termes de
sensations et coutumes au fait le
plaisir les gars de me laisser barré
paul a donc cessé c'est super chouette
parce que c'est fin offrait alors c'est
vraiment l'instrument que t'as pas
l'habitude de manier et
mais en fait c'est même principe que
tous les bateaux fonctionnement pas
pareil mais quand tu as le truc c'est
vraiment super excitant en termes de
geek de vitesse contredit sera vite même
même auprès lâcher pour des bateaux qui
n'ont pas de dérive
c'est vraiment pas mal voir sur bord les
bords de portant alors on n'a pas
attaqué les figures de style l'empannage
du vent mais tu dois te faire les
lorsque j'admire le plus c'est cette
histoire de chorégraphie commune et de
cohésion tu vois où
chacun si chacun joue pas son rôle ça ça
merde jusque là bas jusqu'au démarrage
il ya très très peu de bateaux comme ça
en france et même le à ce point là je
pense que c'est le seul que je connaisse
quoi
apa
c'est une une deuxième découverte ps
dans une ambiance un peu plus musclée
que la première fois la veille du
diamant et la série tout est pour ces
kits pâques du pied parfait
et alors confirmation d'un travail de
dix pages
et l'organe on a perdu 3,4 mais qd même
si quelque chose ne marche pas nous le
retour est assez étonnant parce que
pourquoi venir marche arrière dans les
vagues donc on a fait une figure de
style oh mais finit par un triple axel
triple loots je crois appliquée donc une
très belle note artistique 1 sur la fin
le départ déjà des fins de savary là ça
va ça va aller encore mieux aujourd'hui
ce we want miles mais c'est joli c'est
compare tous ensemble évidemment
c'est la guerre
mais ça va être assez maniable
vraisemblablement après on va voir qui
fait quoi
j'ai la chance d'être avec la vie qui
passe est un patron
black accola on est que rassurer
en échange on appris